[Música]
buenas tardes
somos el grupo decantadoras no haya
voces de resistencia
nosotras hemos venido haciendo el
trabajo
en nuestra comunidad
los alabados son ancestrales
en los años 90 la violencia en nuestra
comunidad estaba demasiado pesada
había una persona quien era que los
llevaba a la alimentación
porque no nos dejaban salir si no tenía
por familia a comprar 20 mil pesos que
no satisfacían y para el día
entonces en el 97 mataron esa persona
entonces nosotros nos pusimos a hacer
composiciones en honor a él se vino el
problema grandísimo del 2002
que se vino la violencia y acabó que
asesinó en 79 personas no sabíamos qué
hacer entonces nos reunimos un grupo de
personas hombres y mujeres y dijimos
bueno pongámonos a hacer composiciones
alusivo a la violencia porque parecía el
estado colombiano mirá acá que en el
rincón del choco hay personas que
merecemos su vida y a ver que los oigan
por todo el medio y que no han estado
invitando a estos eventos
entonces le vamos a cantar un primer
alabado que es los que usamos
tradicionales para fúnebres
por el rostro y por la sangre
jesús ha derramado
[Música]
la sangre
mira la vida es pura
y en busca de su igual amado
una vez
igual
[Música]
en ghana
por la de rostro y por la sangre
[Aplausos]
[Música]
amado
mira la apertura en busca de su hijo
y época
ama
[Música]
las tres leguas que anduve una mujer me
encontrado por la tele martiano de un
amor encontrado y así me buena muerte a
jesús vivas allá
es verdad
me gusta mirar por el rostro y por la
sangre de todas las ramas camina la
virtud y busca deslizado y el mundo en
mis manos
tiempo atrás estoy mamado y en punta de
ley
si lo he encontrado señora piensa cruz
crucificado
y me encontrado señora y el agro
[Música]
una corona de espinas para que haga en
el costado
j
[Música]
y una llama rosa
el rostro y por la sangre que derramas
caminar avilés pura nunca de su amado el
buscar a mi lado y el buscar destruyó a
mano y ajustada
ya jesucristo murió y allá lo llevan
cantando ya jesucristo murió ya ya
tratando de lo van a enterrar
allá en el monte calvario
[Música]
el armario
[Aplausos]
por el rostro y por la sangre y esta
rama
la vida es pura en botas de su amado y
en busca del ganado
y encontrarle vivo a más
eso iba mal
y en busca de su amor
le vamos a cantar anuncios a la
violencia
bueno
nosotros somos víctimas de cobre tiempo
allá
[Música]
de concreto en guayas
vamos a presentar el grupo ya no se
víctima más
[Música]
carlos bertino
respete nuestro derecho para que no
vuelva a pasar
nosotros los vinos y lucha por la paz
[Música]
- y lucha por la paz
estamos más allá
compartiendo resistencia
[Música]
no te vayas
y viajar
con todos nuestros vecinos no queremos
más violencia
nuestros vecinos queremos que se
respeten nuestros derechos porque no me
van a decir los denunciamos por la
los vecinos y luchar por la paz
a los ancestros fallecidos los llevan
nuestro talento los de los fallecidos
no quiero nuestro aliento ya se fueron
para siempre y feliz no produciendo pero
siempre seguimos produciendo vivir él me
he hecho para que no vuelvan a nosotros
los vecinos y luchar
a nosotros también nos escucha
con esta nos despedimos por carlos mucha
atención con esa despedida
mucha atención sobre el grupo y alhama
hoy queremos ver licitación
[Aplausos]
de inflación
m
para que no vuelva a pasar
no todos vecinos y luchamos por la paz
los argentinos y luchar por las otras
los vecinos y luchar por la paz
[Música]
ahorita vamos a cantar
un campo que nosotros les decimos
arrullo o chigualos que es que se le
cantan a los niños cuando fallecen
y dicen
y al pasar por el fuerte de la victoria
de la victoria ay por besar la madrina
fs la novia y andando
me voy navegando para dónde va la caja
por la que los hitos los pastores de
amor
[Música]
en mi enemigo
tarde me lo dijo mi más grande ha dicho
que no me casé con hombre blanco hay
porque parece la vara del campanario y
andando pero la vida no está donde ya
que eso sí yo no sé si digo si miramos
los tres factores que mueven digamos
[Música]
y le digo a mis enemigos mi mamá me ha
dicho que no me case vamos hambre marte
hay porque todas las noches ya este mes
todos y hace método y andando pero me
vuelvo a donde está la casa del conde ya
que esos iconos en actores que me muero
de amor al enemigo
[Música]
mis enemigos mi mamá me ha dicho que no
mientras estamos aprendiendo porque
todas las noches darme consejos y
andando no me baila llegando para donde
la casa del conde era que no si yo no sé
digo hoy me llamaron más tarde miedo de
amar
de mí
de enemigos de mis enemigos me ha dicho
tengo metas te pago exprés flaco porque
todas las noches a las tabaco ya nada no
me vuelo de la tarde a la casa de
escondite a que éstos sí yo no sea y si
digo que estamos rodrigo pastor es mi
nuevo llamado
[Música]
el mismo enemigo y ay de mí
y yo voy por la calle
hay para que digan la gente que soy
bonita y andando dónde voy navegando
donde está la casa del cometa que esto
si yo no sé si no volvería morro de
pastores llamar a mi enemigo de mi
enemigo una mujer junto a su hombre más
peligroso del peligro hay como flores
que caen junto al camino y andando yo me
voy llegando para montes a la casa a ver
porque ya que eso sí no lo sepáis y digo
no me llamo rodillos hasta ahora me
muero de amor
de mi enemigo
de mi pobre de mí
bueno muchas gracias y esperamos que
esto sea un cambio para este país
[Aplausos]